look marvel if every confrontation you
have ends in a fist fight
maybe you've got some issues to work out
[Music]
hey there folks in the wake of the end
of moon night which wrapped up trying to
think of when this video is coming out
uh
not this past wednesday but the
wednesday before
i kind of want to talk about marvel and
more specifically the climax to marvel
products well mcu products in specific
i'm not really going to touch on the
comics too much but you know the films
the disney plus series etc
i say etc as if there's anything else
it's those two things
well i suppose it was the netflix okay
i'm
focus focus come on i can do it
but uh if you saw my review of the
finale of moon knight you can check the
link there i was pretty disappointed
with it not because it was absolutely
bad on its face but because instead of
focusing on all the stuff that i was
really fascinated by was really digging
about the series the psychological
aspects the philosophical aspects the
messing with the mind and just the
exploration of these characters and the
way they interacted
i'm not going to say a guy completely
forgot but it got sidelined in favor of
egyptian god kaiju fights and a brawl
between two characters only one of whom
had made sense to end in an action
sequence and the other of whom had been
a completely psychological and
philosophically based character up to
that point so it frustrated me again not
because the action scenes had no place
in a story like this moon knight had
established that you know there was
going to be action beats there had been
some before
but the fact that it sidelined pretty
much everything that i really liked
about the show
so that it could more fully focus on an
action climax
yeah
didn't love it this is starting to
become an issue for me with marvel now
i understand how this happened part of
it just has to do with the nature of
comic books and the medium they're
adapting from and the other has to do
with the fact that as much variety as
exists in the mcu and i actually stand
by the fact that there is a decent
variety in terms of genre tone and etc
they are ultimately fundamentally all
action products or at least they have
been
and they've started to
stick certain things into the action box
that don't really belong there
again
for a while it made a lot of sense when
you build something like iron man the
thor films hulk etc etc i can use etc
there
that means that you know you are
building these as action films
hero
villain and both are established as
physical threats it will end in a
physical confrontation and that is
valid and that works and sometimes it
even works phenomenally in marvel's best
ending action scenes it is
so exciting and thrilling and triumphant
even but increasingly as time has gone
on i found myself going
do we need that did that need to end in
a fight or did that need to end in a
fight that was as long as it was
i should probably cite some examples now
i've mentioned moon knight already which
i've sort of already said some of the
things but like i feel like it's very
well exemplified by the fact that the
villain harrow played by ethan hawk up
to that point as a villain
was a philosophical threat his
danger what made him dangerous was what
he was trying to unleash and his goals
in doing so
philosophically he was dangerous his
embracing of the idea of you take out
dangerous people before they do anything
dangerous is a
fundamentally
dangerous
concept so that is what made him not
only an intriguing villain but also a
pretty effective one at least to me
however in the end they
give him a magic staff and he just gets
into a fist fight with moon knight
that's not a climax that fits this
villain at all especially given that if
you want just action spectacle he's got
minions you can throw at moon knight
there's the aforementioned egyptian
deity kaiju fight going on in the
background we've got that why is he
being thrown into this combat situation
because we have to end in an action
scene
this is something that i really
complained about earlier in one division
where i argued not only should it not
have ended in an action scene
it shouldn't have had a human villain at
all the instant agatha was revealed the
show almost immediately fell apart for
me because everything that was
interesting and the exploration of what
was going on with wanda in her head her
expressions of it and how other people
either were or weren't dealing with it
what they were weren't learning about it
about her and possibly even about
themselves all went out the window so we
could have a wizard fight in the sky
why this is not a natural climax and
combination of literally anything
that has gone on especially considering
agatha wasn't even built as like a
character embodying the philosophical or
mental conundrums that uh that want to
have been going through she was just
thrown in there so that they could have
a villain to fight at the end and that's
no shade on catherine han i love
catherine han i'm even kind of hopeful
that the house of agatha series will be
entertaining because it'll take her out
of a context where she didn't work
at
all because there needed to be a villain
for there to be a fight i also found
myself actually thinking this a little
bit about uh chongqi
it made sense to have a climactic fight
the characters are all fighters a lot of
the conflict has been filtered through
combat so you might be thinking what are
you talking about you didn't want the
action scene in shanghai not quite where
i was going
rather
the one-on-one fight
between chongqi
and his dad
apparently would have been too low-key
even though that is the
emotional climax of the film and
everything about the conflict and the
characters we are invested in if the
film has done its job well and i think
it did
culminates in that fight and the film
goes on for about another 10 minutes
after that with a big cgi monster fest
a pretty one
a pretty well executed one
but a deeply unnecessary one
there's
really not much reason for that to be
there other than it's not a big enough
spectacle just to have chongqi and his
dad duke it out in a fistfight
it needs to be a bigger action beat now
to be fair there have been in my mind
two times so far where marvel has
managed to give a climax that wasn't
strictly an action scene and in both
cases for me
it worked and actually made these more
interesting as a result the first was in
the original doctor strange oh and i
should probably clear up at time of
recording this i haven't seen doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness yet
so if that ends up being an exception as
well that's why i'm not bringing it up i
haven't seen it yet
okay so
take that off the table
but
the original
doctor strange
there is kind of an action beat between
him and the villain played by mads
mikkelsen uh kaikelius is that his name
i can't remember the guy's name but uh
the thing is that's not really the
climax the climax is the face down with
dormammu
which is not an action scene at all
[Music]
i've come to bargain that's not an
action scene
and it's amazing
i don't know anyone who didn't love that
even people who otherwise didn't really
like the film or don't like doctor
strange overall thought that was cool
because
it's really unique
i mean how many of these films have
ending action sequences where you
actually remember much about the
climactic fights
i'm not going to say there are none
there are some i'd actually argue end
game had a phenomenal climactic action
scene a lot of the beats of which stand
out to me even now
but
a lot of the other ones like it just
kind of
bleeds together the details that i
remember from those films
the things that really stick with me
aren't the action scenes in general and
pretty rarely the climaxes
actually
i think i lied there i said there were
two exceptions there's actually three so
the one that i almost forgot about
captain marvel
does a really great job subverting
the final showdown with uh the person
who has been positioned to be her last
opponent because she just immediately
takes him out and there is no fight i
have nothing to prove to you that having
been said i'd call that a half exception
because there is still a big climactic
fight when she gets fully charged up it
just doesn't include a one-on-one
extended showdown with this final
villain but
i'd say that's a half exception so i
guess two and a half exceptions the
other one
was loki
now the finale of loki i do know there
are some people who don't like it i've
seen them in my comments i loved the
last episode of loki
people complained it's nothing but
exposition dump i don't disagree that it
is but i think it is a masterfully
executed exposition dump portrayed
perfectly
by a villain who is immediately
intriguing and interesting and whose
very concept of what he is and what he
does
challenges the heroes simply by existing
he doesn't have to fight them to be a
challenge to them and for them to have
to think about and overcome
and it's made all the better by the fact
that loki and sylvie
come to different conclusions about what
should be the next thing that happens
so
i really like loki and while there is a
fight it's not
really the climax it's certainly not
much of what the thing is building to
now it is worth pointing out
had loki
not already had a second season
confirmed and had the creators not known
um i guess part way through shooting
that they were going to get a second
season
this might have annoyed me because that
was another thing i noted about moon
knight
the way that everything felt very
hastily wrapped up and at again at time
of recording and i did double check this
there is no second season confirmed
there are hints that there might be a
second season uh when there were tweets
put out uh on official
uh twitter accounts be initially saying
series finale they were deleted and
replaced by ones that said season finale
but even the creators behind that show
have been asked hey does that mean
there's another season and they're
saying uh maybe we don't know so that's
where things stand right now
but i think also that
being positioned that loki i'm now
talking about being positioned as an
ending to a season of a story that would
continue as opposed to the conclusion of
the story maybe that eased some of the
burden on the necessity of having an
action scene i mean maybe not i could be
completely wrong in my speculation about
that being the case but that did work
for me
that
doctor strange and even captain marvel
just by subverting the final fight
because like i was kind of actioned out
by the time she faced off against jude
law's character whose name i also don't
remember
and she just completely took him out
immediately
i really appreciated that first of all
because i actually like it as a moment
inherently and secondly
yeah i i'd had the big action scene i
was done there have been others that
have tried to be a little bit more
subversive but also haven't quite worked
but they've still been more memorable
first guardians of the galaxy comes to
mind for that the actual final showdown
against
uh ronan
ends up being a dance-off
like that's a little different i i
honestly don't think it totally works
but
it also is the culmination at the end of
a very long extended action sequence so
that is i guess another kind of half
exception a bit like captain marvel
where there is a fairly standard
extended climactic action sequence
leading up to an unconventional button
at the end of it
but otherwise it that's yeah
that's a pretty standard action sequence
guardians of the galaxy 2 also a little
bit of a half i suppose because a lot of
what's going on is trying to escape as
opposed to getting active fights with a
lot of what's going on and it's really
just kind of quill and ego battling it
out and even that's pretty
unconventional but it is still an action
scene even if it's escaping the
crumbling planet that's still an action
scene even if it's not a fight scene
action scene and fight scene while
frequently overlapping are not always
the same thing they're not synonymous
action can take a number of different
forms
but anyways
i've now cited some examples so i want
to come back to why i was even bringing
this up my main points
marvel has built its brand
in
action movies now action sub genres
sci-fi action fantasy action action
comedy we've now had things like moon i
dip more into psychological action you
could even argue
but
i really want marvel to branch out i
want it to expand and i want it to grow
and part of how it needs to do that
is to not feel obligated to end
everything
with an action scene
many films
should end with an action scene and
actually i'd say it's going to be harder
for the movies to break away from this
than the series but the series
especially the good series
are delving into characters
and giving us an emotional climax for
the character does not require somebody
get hit in the head with a punch or a
fireball or whatever
sometimes it makes sense it made sense
that hawkeye had an action climax it
made sense
that uh falcon and the winter soldier
had an action climax
it didn't really make sense that what if
had a big crossover action climax
especially considering that what that
show had been about was exploring
individual ideas and then suddenly it's
let's smash everybody together and make
them fight
that one was a little weird but then
again i'm also very lukewarm on what if
so i don't want to go down that road too
far but my point is
marvel
i am a
self-professed
fan
of what you are doing with the mcu and
what you have been doing for quite some
time
however
don't get stuck in a rut
of insisting everything end in an action
sequence
because while it is often
the correct way to end these stories and
while it often fits
the times that it doesn't
really stand out
with again one division probably being
the single worst offender on that
but moon knight
that's not that much better at least for
me
and that in that case less because it
didn't fit and more because
it took away time from the stuff i
actually cared about
understand the priorities of the story
that you have crafted that you have
created
is it more important that this end in a
big cgi fight
or is it more important
that you bring the character's personal
journeys and their emotional arcs to a
satisfying conclusion
because if that's what's more important
maybe you can go lighter on the action
at the end
and maybe in some cases you don't
actually need to do it at all
will those be as mass appealing i don't
know there are some people who certainly
come to marvel for action and it's not
like they're going to be missing out
there's still plenty of action
franchises marvel and i'm not saying i
want those to go away
i'm just saying
there is room for more variety
especially at this point and the more
marvel expands and the more mediums it
goes into
the more i think
there needs to be a bit more of a
shakeup
in what we see
because
if it all starts to look a little too
similar
that's where people even me
might start getting bored
and i don't want to be bored with this
stuff i don't always love it
but i
am invested enough that i want to keep
coming back
more to the point i want to continue
wanting
more of this i don't want to get tired
of it
and a good way to
just keep me more invested will be
for me not to be able to safely assume
it's going to end in a fight
every single time
especially if the story
probably didn't need it
so some random thoughts spurred on by
the ending of moon knight and i don't
think this is a massive problem yet but
it's now a pattern i've seen often
enough with
projects where an action climax didn't
fit but i got one anyway i had to just
say something about it but what are your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
patreon is what pays the bills keeps
this whole operation up and running
ensures that i can afford to do things
like
go see uh doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness uh probably
tomorrow from when i am filming uh but
even if you can't help me out there like
share subscribe they all assist
but um don't worry too much about it
i'm not going to tell you how this thing
has to end
instead i'm just going to say that you
are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin luthfalla turock oliver b melinda
walters imudelki the oath of boy tt for
nabi lax the poodle zach paul idoln
tracy scrappet vincent paul bartolucci
angry casper toku bl whovian adam rdl
taylor shane ross shaylee gourley and
brendan larose you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out rewards
on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]